guarda questo che vivo si muove
labirinto dispetto sfida finale turno
benvenuti in sostanza oggi il nuovissimo
episodio veronesi promo super
particolare superbella prega perché
anche paurosa vede che noi adoriamo le
cose pauroso di infatti dovremmo
scappare da una casa infestata nova cosa
penso da fantasmi vampiri mostri in più
dobbiamo andare in giro a fare dolcetto
scherzetto infatti vince chi raccoglierà
più caramelle infatti vediamo se vincerò
io per evitare code si tratta di
caramelle cosa ci potrebbe sincere vita
rilievo le prende tutte le caramelle e
mi piace se questo video 16 mila mi
piace fare un'altra skip room paurosa
solo invitalia ci mangiano a tutto mi
piace questo mettetevi comodi brevi poco
o niente non mi seguite preso integra
mandati a seguirmi mettetevi comodi
iniziamo subito allora eccoci qua
abbiamo già il nostro pennello di
halloween con la zucca per raccogliere
tutte le iene ma dobbiamo buttare nel
seme se forse ho fatto un sacco di farah
membri
news a 581 728 parte dobbiamo andare qui
nelle altre case sì ma non me ne rubare
o no
ma dove sta la casa infestata in cui
dobbiamo entrare ovunque
non lo so io ti sta rubando tutte le
caravelle troppo tardi grazie ed hanno
un tacco di caramelle questa funzione
perché qua nella strada passano le
macchine e tiziano c'è pure una
bicicletta russo sembra cosa ti
rimandano quindi prima dobbiamo sotto la
macchina prendere più caramelle
possibile e poi penso che inizieremo
andare nella casa infestata lei lascia
queste sono mie
a quanto e caramelle style 1946 no se
già provati diversi
quante 1881 sta avvicinando quindi devo
a superarlo quindi dobbiamo trovare
forse dobbiamo riempire tutta quella
barra rossa lì con le caramelle del suo
tempo e le potere 3 nella casistica sono
tantissimi e 10mila per o meno
guarda questa persona del giorno questa
è la casa di cui tutti stanno parlando
dobbiamo andare ad esplorarla vai prima
tu perché io paura ecco la casa
infettata sembra piccola l'acqua ma come
l'impressione che d'entrata ranci piante
prendiamo e ma ma ma ci fa incontrare
forse dobbiamo salire da qui mi piace il
mio outfit e le mie orecchie da gatto
nero io purtroppo non ci fa entrare
nella casa infestata ancora penso perché
dobbiamo prima prendere 10 mila
caravelle vorremmo che rese prima allora
io 7.675 8.360 maroni ha operato subito
a prendermi tantissimo l'aspetto sono
9.116 8700 computato non ci preme hai
già preso 10 genere a me non mi sto
facendo entrare nella casa ho detto se
ho vinto dai ti aspetto qui solo perché
si tratta di cibo ha vinto vitale per il
concordo dai ti manca poco anche a te
adesso sono 100 caramelle di mancano
vediamo si no brava anch'io
vediamo cosa ci aspetta capitolo una
allora vediamo cosa dice che porta
interessanti con numeri diversi sopra
credo che dovremmo andare i morti numeri
eccoci qua altra il titolo 1 dobbiamo
saltare sopra queste o via da giganti
sentivo che marcano
quindi la sfida che altro vitale
continua una casa dentro una casa
agibile 3
guarda i ragni penso che dobbiamo stare
mi ha preso il ragno devi aspettare che
si spostano e li aiuto caramella miglia
a dover vitale ancora in mezzo ai ragni
preso eco vitale e vitale di g a
colorare o già sbloccato il capitolo 2
wow ma siamo stati velocissimi e
bravissimi diventerà sempre più
difficile che cosa disse guarda ci sono
delle zucche avuti quando gli anti
vorrei tornarmene a casa
fratello che ballo in siri volanti porta
misteriosà cosa succederà qua vediamo
che dice dice questa è l'unica strada
per uscire
beh allora sai cosa devi fare beh sì
saltare questi a quanto pare dobbiamo
saltare su questi pezzi di pavimento che
sono un po in bilico toccati al muro sei
troppo sopra canton o comunque ad
orbetello paurosa mi ricorda il film
nightmare è uno dei miti e voi l'avete
visto questo un po più complicato perché
bisogna sono tipo dizioni sul pavimento
adoro tutte cose paurose penso il numero
10 di share
salti slime osì guarda questo occhio e
vivo si muove così anche un teschio
attenta tenta fatta sono i fantastico
che carini sono troppo carini questi
fattori è così cordiale e se pensi di
aver visto delle chiavi la ma dovrei
stare molto attento conoscendo questa
casa c'è 81 e rossi e altri segni la
chiave sbagliata qualcosa di brutto
succederà io scelgo nokia la rossa qui
su questi piccoli como di una rossa e
una blu io prendo quella blu ok ho preso
quella
no era quella sbagliata ma importanti ma
che bello anche questa musica via
capitolo iii ed ossa perché chiuse fuori
evitarle dice di scappare veloso 20 dal
fienile perché sta andando a fuoco la
comproprietà non è stata bella
vediamo forse sopra si può andare io
sono già note ragioni di salire sulla
scala che è divertente
mai finora non siamo dove dobbiamo
andare un pò riusciti a scappare sono
saltato la crisi quante caramelle
dobbiamo salire sul fieno guarda cosa
sono queste luci
no aspetta mi sono più attento a non
cadere sotto
sì l'ho fatta ma bisogna evitare questi
come si chiamano for coi forconi piano
piano si no
c'è un labirinto ad ora i lavori
mazzetta invece qualcosa che cos'è a
materasso
allora dobbiamo stare attenti in questo
labirinto attenti a non perdersi che ci
sono delle zucche quante caramelle ma
questa sembra la stessa strada di prima
no no no noi siamo riusciti a uscire
wow guarda sono delle zucche fantasmi
zucche fantasma penso che ti sfracellano
lo stesso anche se sono fantasmi no
comporta moda guardate avete non hanno
la maglietta di vita e vitale ha fatto
la sua maglietta capitale è scoperto
almeno mi riconosco che dice corale in
cui bisogna correre a scatola aspetto
latina per un po divertenti prima rete
di cioccolato infatti vitale secondo me
non mi distrae adesso le caramelle
mi sembra abitare le caramelle non
bisogna prendere aiuta che bello davanti
riproviamo ma secondo me è
difficilissimo come quello come il
livello 10 del dolo ve lo ricordate
se non l'avete vista andate a vederlo
dopo questo video perché è stato
difficile il famoso livello di città
la fantasia e proviamo piano piano che
hanno e via ha visto che proprio lì dal
bordeaux io invece non pensavo si
potesse andare così devi fare tipo
piccolissimi pozzetti per non correre ci
hanno fatto quasi fase calante
dovete fare ha detto sulle caramelle ci
sono quasi ci sono quasi dai non posso
perdere adesso sta andando bene
arrivando anch'io
devi fare piccolissimi pacchetti per non
cadere
ecco vita nella zona tramonto siamo
luminosi wow dai tuoi farcela non sono
un po allora pasti piccolissimi e via
[Musica]
ieri dai vitale puoi farcela dai manca
pochissimo non possiamo perdere qua
siamo nel portale
il nodo difficile però ce l'abbiamo
fatta capitolo 4 battuta però come fa
tutto questo a stare dentro alla casa
guardano giù un pagliaccio super
inquieta vuole no penso che siamo finiti
in un parco di divertimenti horror
pauroso come quello di 1 1 la prima
escape room che abbiamo fatto se non
avete visto linea vederlo è troppo
divertente
wow d'oro troppo bravo un divertimento e
adoro le cose paurose quindi adoro i
partiti diversi
no sono già morto ora dice per favore
non dirmi che dobbiamo saltare sui
palloncini per uscire da qua speriamo
che reggano il nostro paese beh forse il
mio peso lo reggono quello di dentista
ma se lo dico signora tv aggiunga troppo
divertente perché i primi sono abbiamo
stati da qui dobbiamo stare dentro
l'amore del pagliaccio
ok che wow tipo un'illusione ottica
aggirarono a te non mi lasciare solo hai
paura nel paese labirinto dispetto d'oro
cinema è entrato in un labirinto di
specchi così tante volte con una volta
una mia amica se anche sbagliatissimo in
ospedale perché in pratica ci sono sia
gli specchi sia i vetri di capire da che
parte andare
anm è un po difficile capire da che
parte andare ed è di corse di cuore
bloccato dopo attenti a non perdersi o
no non ci separiamo noster cioè chiusa
allora dobbiamo trovare un'altra uscita
è chiuso anche qua forse di qua dai guai
io vado qua si sa di quale di qua dove
sono io ma anche valori tornato indietro
è difficilissimo forse qua
ok forse abbiamo trovato la strada no è
chiuso ma è troppo difficile dobbiamo
concentrarci allora vediamo siamo
arrivati già mi sono dimenticato di dire
che ci siamo persi sto perdendo il senso
dell'orientamento è tutto uguale è
chiuso anche qua ma dove stiamo forse
timori fa sentire questa strada
tutti uguali non si capisce no aspetta
feci sorte non ci credo sia un rischio
wow meno male avevo paura che siamo
rimasti chiusi
vinta per 1
questo fa un po paura sono dei pagliacci
ma meta di codici ci sono dei pagliacci
appesi salsicce spizzicare forestali qua
sul muro mou è più difficile che ti
prendano nome allora ali sul lato
ecco vitale dare poi vari effettivamente
più semplice o spiaccicato proprio alla
fine
ok risalite giocavamo nel portale
capitolo capitolo non ci credo che ci
siamo quasi riusciti che così qua dice
mi chiedo questo stessero costruirlo qua
stavano costruendo qualcosa sicuramente
qualcosa di inquietante di questa casa
delle sembianze un po da mosto guarda
una casa alle braccia
i denti sembra un mostro oppure
sentimento o no avete presente cosa
succede in ogni skip room
dobbiamo entrare nella bocca di qualcuno
che il rublo paura che anche questa
volta la casa vogliamo a girarsi e ri
entreremo nella bocca nella casa vediamo
di non cadere qua sto arrivando dove se
ne andavano
non lo so caduto è la strada giusta
ah sì ecco c'è qualcuno qui c'è scritto
di prendere la dinamite per riuscire a
scappare da qua è doppia visto la
nascita trovato cinque qua intorno
quindi dobbiamo prenderle portargliele
stai attento perché ho paura che queste
che mancano studi accecati attenta
perché sono super veloci ok ho preso una
eco vitale spiaccicato per fortuna anche
se ti spiazzi che non rimane la dinamite
a ben 2
è bravo solo 2 dove saranno ecco l'altro
quattro non si arrivò a devo stare qua
ok anch'io ne ho quattro dove la quinta
persona dove sarà la vita era là sopra
guarda dobbiamo tornare indietro
ok fresca succede vuole far esplodere
tutto dobbiamo portarla qui figli sfida
finale o no la carta la casa ha preso
vita è diventata un mostro di gas sta
credono di rabbit e aiuto
noi dobbiamo scappare abitiamo data dice
e se di prendere la dinamite prima che
esploda ok quando la casa ci tira di
vanità dobbiamo raccogliere a ritirargli
la prima che esploda e visto colpa
gravissima abbiamo colpirla tante volte
però che io credo che ho capito vai vai
vai cinque volte la dobbiamo colpire
favoriti ma questa casa marvel e dc con
10 avvicinare stato troppo tardi
rossetto abita a pila corridoi ritrovare
valutare dove star non la vedo è qui e
qui tanti avvicinare l'offerta in italia
che succede eccola qui di fronte a te è
tornata è distrutta grande evento si
dice hai vinto guarda ci credo abbiamo
anche un video dalla spagna ma è stato
troppo divertente è raro trovare anche
il mostro
quindi gli do un bel 10 anch'io 10 aver
troppo divertente alla di mozione finale
quando il mostro
e voi che voto gli date ma soprattutto
chi è raccolto più caramelle a rick
azionisti ha raccolto 47
senta io non ci credo anch'io perché si
tratta di caramelle e quindi è normale
che le trovo tutte io mi piace passate
su cui cliccare per vedere i nostri
altri video licata su quella che
preferite